[Music]
okay
2188
we're actually playing really strong
opponent again i've i've been playing d4
a little bit more on the speed run so
let's go d4 i could play london i mean i
could play london but there's just so
much material available on the london
that i think mainlines
are a better use of our time so let's go
c4
yeah i could play a catalan okay benoni
minoni we're gonna go d5
and a benko gambit
okay so bangkok gambit i i don't know
that well
i'm gonna play an old line that my coach
taught me years ago a rare move now of
course c takes b5 is is topical that
that's what the books recommend but i'm
going to play an old soviet line which
is knight d2
this is not a well-known move at all but
it but it has some teeth the point is to
meet b take c4 with e4 so you're almost
reversing the gambit and you're sacking
upon yourself of course it's temporary
because we're going to win this pawn
back yeah and nobody knows the correct
move here which i'll talk about after
the game the correct move is actually c3
to give the punt back in order to damage
white's pawn structure now we take on c4
of course with the bishop because
otherwise the pawn on e4 hanks and white
is a slight but stable advantage here
g6 cool well
we have to develop our pieces there's
not much to say here knight gf3 but it's
a good version of a bononi for now maybe
it was worth playing h3 first
to stop bishop g4 i'm not too concerned
about bishop g4 though knight bd7 okay
again no real threats here
we should castle
there's this idea in in the benko
and it also exists in the benoni to play
knight g4
and then transfer the knight over to e5
so it would make sense here i think for
us to play
the move h3 to restrict
the knight on f6 and then maybe make a
move like queen c2 to solidify
solidify the center lend a little bit
more support to the pawn on e4 the
problem we ultimately want to solve here
with white
is we want to deploy this bishop onto b2
but we need to be careful of course
because if we play b3 now we run into
tactics with knight takes c4 so at some
point we're gonna play rook b1 then b3
and bishop b2 let's start with the move
h3
yeah now i think rookie one of course is
is is is very good the move rookie one
is always a good move to throw in we
could also play rook b1
and straight away we could solve the
problem of the bishop
so we've got
a bunch of different choices here i like
rookie one a lot too let's go rookie one
let's just keep keep improving our
position perhaps later in the game we
could play e5
knight p6 yeah yeah this is how you
should play this with black
so now i like the concept potentially of
giving away this bishop this bishop is
not very good in this particular
line we could also play bishop b5 bishop
c6 that would be a possibility in
general i like to move queen c2 because
if if black takes the bishop then we
take back with the knight and we have
easy prospects for our dark squared
bishop i don't love giving black the
bishop pair
but on the other hand
it's really would be a big help for us
if
if we could deploy our knight to c4 so
it's a trade-off let's go queen c2
knight fd7 okay
an ft7
okay that i don't think is the best move
because that makes it hard for black to
play e6 later in the game
now i think we should move our bishop
where should we move it well
the typical square is f1 we could also
move it to b5 and after inducing a6 we
could then move it back to f1 let's do
that let's go to b5 let's try to be a
little bit annoying we should also
accelerate our pace here a little bit
yeah i also like the idea of going a4 a5
because a5 actually traps he goes a5
himself
okay now here's the setup that we are
going to adopt we're going to play a4
and fix the pawn in place
and then rather than going rook b1 b3
bishop b2 we have a second very
interesting maneuver let's take this
we have
another very interesting setup which is
to play
rook a3
swing this rook to the center to e3 for
example or maybe d3 and then play b3
not 100 sold on this idea myself but
let's try to play creatively now we also
can play b3 here if necessary the rook
will look terrible on a3 we could bring
it back to a1 the position is closed
we don't need to
conquer everest on every move e6 but
this kind of justifies the idea of rook
a3 so now i think we should take i think
we should take
okay and now
so we could go with d3 then black goes
d5 we take and go b3 that looks pretty
decent because white's
black's pawns in the resulting position
are going to be pretty flimsy they're
going to be i like that idea let's go
rook d3 now it looks like we're giving
black control of the center but i'm
banking on the fact that black is gonna
have to invest a lot of resources to
maintain
that center also the move d5 gives this
the center it gives the rook on e1
really good prospects
oh yeah queen d3 oh queen d3 would have
won the pawn wouldn't it oh no it
wouldn't have actually quindy 3 queen c8
and we can't take on d6 because of
knight c4 but i missed
i didn't follow my own advice i i didn't
notice the rook was undefended no knight
c4 doesn't win a pawn knight c4 he can
go queen c7 for example queen e7 okay
that doesn't change our strategy we go
b3
actually queen e7 might be inaccurate
because now black can no longer play d5
at least for the time being 95 okay
obviously we trade white is better here
no question about it okay now
we could play
bishop b2 now rather than than rushing
with that move i think we can throw in
an improving move before we play bishop
b2 what is that improving move we can
also chase the bishop out of e5 which in
turn
weakens the
d6 pawn
so let's go knight f3
okay bishop or knight t7 so now how am i
thinking about this position well
it's clear that our our overarching plan
here is to attack the d6 pawn and to put
pressure on black center as a whole so
we need to figure out which pieces are
not working to their fullest potential
in that regard we could trade on e5
that's not a bad idea actually i think
the bishop is better in that resulting
position than the knight
but the other move i like is is rook e
to d1
simply to increase the pressure
on the d6 pawn so the two candidate
candidate moves here are taking the
downside of taking is that black takes
back with a knight and hits our rook i
don't want to lose that tempo
that's that's kind of annoying to me so
let's go with the second candidate move
rook e to d1
yeah and on the next move if we get a
chance we can maybe take on e5 or we
could play bishop b2 and continue
softening up the d6 one
this is an unpleasant position for black
rook b6 that's a great move though
our opponent doing what he can to
generate activity okay now i'm really
really tempted to take that bishop i'm
really tempted to take that and then
swing the rook to g3
so division of labor one rook attacks d6
the other rook pressure is the king
let's do it we might not have another
chance let's do it let's go rook g3
and on the next move we're finally i
think going to develop the bishop to b2
so we've got a nice position we've got
four minutes so i i will have to
speed up a little bit bishop queen f6
queen f6
so f4
is a very tempting move because knight
c6 rook takes oh then he has knight d4
there's tactics there yeah so probably
should be two makes the most sense
[ __ ] queen f4
important position here to play
accurately and bishop h6
is also very interesting let's go
let's go to h6
now there's a couple of subtleties here
to to bear in mind
one of which is that if black goes rook
f's okay rook b8 not expecting that for
whatever reason because the pressure on
this pawn is not very serious all right
what do we do now queen d2 looks really
interesting that would hit the pawn on
a5 it would also pressure d6
let's go
queen d2
just continuing to kind of
oh and i forgot about f4 but f4 he had
knight f7 so that would have been
subpar my bad yeah i'm thank you jamil j
so sorry i was a little bit distracted i
appreciate it
c4
okay i think we have to take
knight takes and then go queen e2 for
example
yeah let's take it
okay queen e2
makes a lot of sense here attacking the
knight
let's do it
rook beach oh rook b2 i missed that
but that's that's a blunder that's a
blunder and this is a classic example of
making an assumption about the position
false assumption about the position
because he thinks that queen takes d4 is
impossible thinks that queen takes c4 is
impossible but then there's queen takes
f2
right and that looks like may but it's
not made because we just have king h2
we just have king h2 and the rook on g3
defends the pawn on g2 i don't see a
follow-up there
well if he takes to the rook then
there's nothing we just got queen d4
for instance forcing the queen trade
yeah king h1 is also good in h1 queen
takes g3 and we can take on e6 good
catch that is mate
okay and he resigns that's a bit of a
disappointing finale but
i i
would say that that's partially a result
of all the pressure that we put on black
lackluster final for sure but it was an
interesting middle game
a lot to to delve into
something i said earlier probably a
couple of maybe 200 300 points ago
which is that the games of course become
a lot more technical and it becomes a
lot harder to explain certain things in
two or three sentences so that's why
i offload a lot of that to after the
game so if you're
14 1500 or less then you really want to
pay more attention to
the way i explain stuff after the game
and you want to make sure that you
understand the basics of why i made the
moves i made
um rather than you know for example
freaking out about
like why i didn't play one particular
move over another like in many cases
there are viable alternatives
yeah yeah i was i was just there so the
benko gambit
is a very interesting opening
it's it's an underrated opening
but there's one major like fundamental
flaw with having the benko as your main
opening
which is that it's very very easy to
avoid it like white can go
knight f3 move two
and you can't play the benko the same
problem if you play the budapest gambit
like you're gonna have to learn
something on top of the benko thank you
mgn7 now this
what you can do here is you you can play
c5 d5 and now b5
so this is a viable
system i don't remember apparently this
is called the spielman indian
pseudo-benko variation
but to my knowledge this is not
considered very good for black
theoretically i think bishop g5 here is
supposed to give white
a pretty hefty advantage you could
analyze this on your own maybe this is
uh tenable
um but a lot of banker players do this
to avoid having to learn
a completely different opening
but anyways knight f6 we played c4 c5
d5
now if you're a white player who wants
to avoid the benoni in the benko you can
also play the move e3 here it's quite
passive but it's very very solid
you also have the move knight f3 so
there are ways that you can avoid
the bononi and the benko if you're if
you're white
okay so d5 b5
and here
there are a gazillion different viable
setups
now what shanklin recommends in his uh
course
and what has been recommended i think in
books of the past couple of years is
this line
which has really caused the benko to
stop being played at a grand master
level if you if you check
gm games the benco has gotten very very
rare
and it's
generally accepted that this line gives
white a pretty big advantage
and if i'm not mistaken this line is
basically knight c3
bishop takes a6 and now the move e4
now the move e4 you allow
bishop takes f1 king takes f1 and the
general idea is that you fiancado the
king on g2 and the king is going to be
quite safe there and
according to modern engines
it seems that black
does not have sufficient compensation
for the pawn that doesn't mean that you
can't play this that doesn't mean that
at a 1600 level
you know this is untenable it just means
that magnus carlsen is not going to play
it with black against geary
so this line this line is considered
better for white
you might wonder like what even the
point of the benko gamut is like it
doesn't just give way to protected past
pawn
it does
but when the bengal works it it really
is an amazing opening like when this
pawn sacrifice yields serious queen side
counter play you can win
some really really pretty and smooth
games in the benko
but i want to give you a a taste of what
the benko looks like
when it actually works like what does
black's queen side attack
actually look like i had a game
years ago in the king's indian but i
applied the benko gambit idea
so he got a position that was very very
similar to something that would come out
of a benko and my opponent played it
very poorly which
you know allowed me to illustrate some
of the basic ideas of the benko so this
is from the world youth 2013. this was a
king's indian of course because that's
what i play
um i have three castles bishop e3
same-ish variation a6 and here i am
i was preparing for the game and i came
up with a
with an interesting line knight fd7
weird-looking move
the point is you go c5 and you open up
the bishop accentuating the pressure
you'll see what the point of a6 is in a
second
so here he goes knight castles
knight c6 and already bad play by white
he goes d5
this gives me
the bishop pair i mean now i go knight
e5 and he has to keep his bishop on d3
otherwise i win the pawn on c4
knight c1
knight takes uh oh no and i go b5 i
actually want b5
right here and right now
leading to the benko gamut structure cb5
now i take the bishop
and now i take the pawn and we get
this position
but in comparison to the actual benko
like this is incomparably
favorable for black because we've got
this monster bishop on g7 we've got the
bishop pair
and you'll see how important that is in
a second and
the initiative
develops by itself
we go bishop a6 now white should have
gone a4 here and defended the night but
instead he drops back
bang queen a5 this is
the world's best mango queen c2 rook fba
just accumulating all of the pieces on
the queen side rook ft1 and now it's
already time for concrete measures i
actually found an idea that just wins
the game right away
so
bishop takes d3 you give away the bishop
what is the point who can tell me what
subsequent maneuver gives black
insurmountable pressure
yeah exactly so the point is to get the
knight to c4 you go 95 with tempo then
you bring the knight to c4 the bishop
has to drop back to c1
now i considered the tactic knight takes
b2 but i rejected it because
at the end of the line
okay black is better but this is not
this is not convincing enough
this is not convincing enough so rather
than caching this is a very common
mistake cashing in
too quickly rather than
accumulating the pressure and cashing in
at an appropriate moment
so
i found a really strong move here that
leads to the collapse of white's
position and that's the simple queen
before
i mean you just attack the b2 pawn
white can't play b3 because the knight
hangs
rook b won the knight hangs as well it's
totally crushing
so white played a3 and now we stick the
queen on to b3
trade rook a2 double on b8 and now when
i win the pawn on b2 it's completely
winning
a4 knight takes b2
this is this is over because the rook
easily stops white's pawn
okay he went knight a7 and we just push
yeah nice tactics here by the way rook
takes a4 if knight takes c2 then rook c4
and bishop b2 was unstoppable winning
the knight
knight t3 rook a1 trade king f2 and
bishop b2
white resigned easy game i think i i
usually
you know i'm not a time trouble junkie
but i usually take most of my time this
game i think i only took like 30 40
minutes
uh because all of the moves are really
really natural
can you show the whole line that is bad
for black in the banco
yeah so
well i just did the line that's that's
considered um
considered bad for black is so a6
b oops not b6 b6 is a move also
ba
thank you keep proxy now g6 is more
popular than bishop takes a6 is the
pawn's not going anywhere it transposes
into each other bishop takes a6 and the
move is e4
and this is still very popular if you
look this up online you'll still see a
ton of gm games from 2022 even
but um yeah e3 is also a good sideline
that's true
but but if you if you check with a
strong engine
light is better that's not really up for
debate
but again i need to hammer this point
home because it's i think often
mistransmitted by people which is that
if you listen to magnus talking about a
line he says well this line is worse for
black
that doesn't mean you can't play it
and i know many like people in the 1800
2000 range who are successful banco
players if you're a tactical player this
if you like gambits this is a great
opening
um to play anywhere under gm level so
just because something is untenable at a
2750 level in fact the king's indian i
would say
is basically untenable at that level
even i play it full time
um so just keep that straight in your
mind
but i didn't go for this line because i
don't know it
um or i don't know the subsequent
there's a lot of theory after that
obviously so we played this old line
that my coach taught me knight d2
bc and e4
uh knight d2 is not common at all it's
probably the sixth seventh most common
move
but the benko is very good at teaching
you like basic
gambit strategy and positional ideas
because all of the pressure occurs on
the queen side you have to learn how to
pressure the side of the board that the
opponent's king is not on
okay
so d6
is to my knowledge maybe the theory has
changed
i mean maybe this is fine now but
the way i remember it is c3 is the best
move b takes c3
and now
uh g6 yeah this is the main line g6 c4
d6 bishop b2 bishop g7 and you get a
position like this i think this is
probably close to equal
but it's pretty easy to play this for
white knight gf3 and bishop d3 and i
just think that white's development here
is very natural
so this is a quick and easy line that
you can play
he didn't play that he plays d6
now we play bishop takes c4 why c3 what
is the purpose of the move see through
the purpose of the move is that you're
going to lose that pawn anyway so you
might as well damage you might as well
damage white structure while you're at
it classic idea in so many different
lines
using you're already going to lose a
pawn so you give it away
for
to ruin your opponent's structure maybe
the most famous
instance of this is in the fianchetto
grunfeld
in the symmetrical fiance grunfeld
there's a line you've seen me play and
probably where white goes knight a3 and
black ghost c3 giving away the c pawn
this way
to create some weaknesses in white
structure isn't there an important
argument that this strengthens white's
center
uh yes but white center is strong and
that's true
but everything's a trade-off like the
logic is that
the damage
is permanent to the pawn structure
whereas the center is pretty strong
anyway you don't really care that
there's another pawn in the center here
okay anyways
so d6 bishop c4 g6
knight gf3
and bd7 so i think white is slightly
better here uh good development so we
played h3 to avoid the idea of knight g4
and knight e5 so we we restrict the
knight on f6
castles and this is one of those
positions which often occurs in d4
openings now d4 openings overall i think
are a little bit more
undefined maybe is the word than e4
openings with a lot of e4 openings like
there's a very clear system of
development the theory extends to move
20 or more whereas in some d4 openings
you just get positions where you have to
learn to play
general improving moves and it isn't
about finding the best move it's about
just making a series of reasonable
improving moves and this is a great
example of such a position where does
the light square bishop belong in the
end well c4 is fine for now it's not the
greatest square but you can drop it back
to f1 later to make space for the knight
to enter the c4 square which if you play
the bononi with white you know that the
c4 square for the knight is probably the
best on the board
okay so we played rookie one black plays
knight p6 and here we decided to leave
the bishop on c4 with this move queen c2
potentially connecting the rooks the
queen is just better placed on c2 than
it is on d1 because it supports the pawn
it's just a nice square it's a nice
little pocket for the queen i'm not
i'm not convinced maybe black should
have taken the bishop and gone like
bishop a6 for instance
the other thing that that i that enticed
me about this is that we get easy
development for the dark scored bishop
bishop g5 but maybe now that i look at
this
once it's on the board i'm realizing
that maybe this wasn't worth it because
black's work can get to b4 maybe giving
away the bishop wasn't worth it
so maybe it was a better idea to play
bishop f1 interesting question something
to explore but anyways black didn't take
it knight ft-7 now we decided to
conserve the bishop and structures like
this where both castle king said and one
king of fiance no it's not jurash at all
it's a very rich position in fact it's
like anti-drag there's there's so much
life in the game it's just that there's
no contact between the sides yet right
just because there's no attack on one of
the sides kings doesn't mean that you
know there's no life in the position so
we played bishop b5
leading to a very interesting uh middle
game i'll be right back
i always feel
like i get impatient trying to develop
my dark scored position in these menoni
structures
any advice we're coming up where to
place it where basically
there's two places to put the dark
square bishop you can develop it along
this diagonal or you can develop it
along this diagonal the reason i like
the b2 square is because it challenges
black sphere and keto bishop right the
fiend ghetto bishop when it's
uncontested is one of the best pieces on
the board because it controls the long
diagonal and it it's just annoying so it
makes logical sense that you would want
to contest it by by putting your own
bishop on b2
and there's also a tremendous amount of
gain to extract from trading off
a fiance bishop when one side has this
hole
in their position and the other side
doesn't
that's already serious attacking chances
so for instance
let's assume that like we
let's just make a couple random moves
for black let's assume that we get the
bishops off the board we get our chance
to put our bishop on b2
what is the consequence of this trade
well you can see that there are holes on
the king's side which later on in the
game imagine if you stick a queen on h6
like that could win you the game at some
point down the line a lot of newer
players have a hard time conceptualizing
this because you're like well the queen
is not even on a position where it can
get to h6 but that's not the point the
point is in chess you have to build up
your short-term advantages and you have
to build up your long-term advantages
and in these highly strategic positional
situations
it's all about building up your your
long-term
you're investing in the long run and
stuff that could happen and only benefit
you like 10 15 moves down the line
yeah of course you don't have a dark
sword bishop so
you will have a problem explaining the
dark squares but not as much
okay so a5
now we play a4
and the purpose of the move a4 well we
don't want black to play it for like if
we go rook b1
one annoying thing that could happen is
black can go a4 and if we go b3 black
could go a3
and prevent us
from developing our bishop that's now
you might look at this and say isn't
this a weak pawn it is but it's not easy
to attack it because
knight c4 black will take it's really
not that easy to get to this pawn and
we're we're really cramped on the queen
side i didn't want to allow that so we
play a4
okay bishop a6 now you should not if you
have a fiance bishop you should treasure
it does that mean you never traded no
there's no such thing as never always in
chess
so bishop a6
our opponent is playing decently we
trade the bishops
now you might wonder why i didn't go
bishop c6
uh and there's a specific reason for
that the problem is that when black
moves his rook black moves there rook
what is black's next move going to be
there's a very annoying idea here that
is hard to stop
very good knight b8
knight b8 is is is very concerning and
we're going to have to drop our bishop
back to b5 now you might say what's the
problem with that well the problem with
that
is we don't want this scenario at all
this pawn is a huge weakness it's a big
liability black can easily attack it and
black can shove this one down to a4
but this not to mention that this loses
a bunch of tempe so for that reason we
trade and now the concept of being
flexible with your ideas and decision
making is rook v1 a decent move
absolutely we have the same plan of b3
bishop too but i saw an opportunity here
to
uh to squeeze a little bit more juice
out of our rook position so that's why i
played rook a3 also if you know anything
about benoni structures you know that
one of black's main ideas is to open up
the center with the movie six it just is
that's just one of black's main ideas in
this position because if the position
remains closed then black is quite
cramped we have this pawn on d5 we have
better control of the center
and we have a very clear plan while
black doesn't so i was expecting e6
which our opponent played understanding
that yields the further insight that
after the trade we can deploy this rook
onto d3 in order to pressure
black's center so if you compare this
position to rook b1
well it's there's no comparison imagine
a rook being on d3 here or on b1 where
is the rook better well obviously it's
better on d3 now you might then say well
wait a minute what if black doesn't play
e6 then aren't don't we look stupid for
putting our rook on it not really
because this is also part of our other
plan to go b3 right so you're
essentially buying insurance policy
against e6 which our opponent played
anyway if he doesn't play it
nbd no big deal then we just go b3
bishop b2 we can always move the roof
back we can always go rookie 3 and then
b3 and have a rookie in the center
you know have it be ready for various
stuff to happen
does that make sense
okay so e6 our opponent played e6 we
trade and we go rook d3 another
important point is that d5 a lot of
people would be scared
by this position because it looks like
oh we've given up our center and black
has two puns in the center and we have
zero hopefully you've watched enough
speedrun to know that that is not a a
acceptable way to evaluate a position
who has more pawns in the center uh if
you're a beginner that's something you
should pay attention to if you're an
advanced player then it's not about who
has more pawns in the center it's about
the quality of those pawns what is the
point of brookie well it just attacks
the pawn right it pressures black's
center
and what what should we play here what
should white do in this position and by
the way if you're watching this on
twitch and youtube where you're a
beginner
and you're not you know this is sailing
some of this is sailing over your head
that that's to be understood remember
that we are at at a high level just try
to extract
you know some of the basics it's like
learning a language right if you're
learning a language you're watching a
movie in that language you're not going
to understand every word but if you
understand some of it that already will
contribute toward your learning so nike
5 blunders the knight
otherwise we'd play knight g5 the move
is b3 nothing happened to our old plan
we still want to trade
in fact now that the position has opened
up we especially want to trade black's
dark square bishop why because it's
going to be easier to access black's
king we have an avenue now the e-file
that we can use later on down the line
to access black sing for example again
let's make a couple of random moves
um
it will not take long for us to create
mate threats and guess what it's because
black's bishop is gone that there are
even
uh that these mape threats are available
so what you should understand about this
position is that
it's like black has to invest so many
resources just to maintain
their center you know the fact of the
matter the knight on b6 is completely
tied down to the pawn the moment black
pushes any
either of these pawns
all hell breaks loose tons of squares
are weakened we get great prospects for
our pieces the bishop is blocked in
so this is an important position to
fully understand why white is better
here it's just because we have such
pressure on the center black's pieces
are discombobulated we're going bishop
b2 on the next move
and and this is black is not having a
good time here at all
so queen e7 right black doesn't go d5
black does not go d5
but we still play b3 nothing has
happened
to our plan we go b3
black goes 95 we trade
and here
of course we can play bishop b2
which would be most consistent with our
plan but i thought we could extract a
little more juice from the position
by first bringing our knight onto a
better position onto f3 and it's
important here to be flexible so for
example
if black drops the bishop back to g7
rather than playing oh why not knight c4
was the question well knight c4 leads to
a trade
i'm not sure why why
y'all are
are
so sure that this trade benefits white
if you trade all the pieces off the
board
you're not going to have any instruments
with which to pressure black center
you have to be careful about that
so i feel like knight c4 is i'm gonna
make a diagnosis of one move itis
i think you like this move because you
like the idea that you're attacking the
rook and you're pressuring the pawn but
if you take that logic one move further
i'm just gonna go rook before and chase
your queen out of there what do you
really gain from that nitrate and
night on b6 has zero prospects it's
totally restricted by white's pawn so
trading knights doesn't really make
sense from
a positional perspective either so
knight f3
if bishop g7
rather than going bishop b2 we can also
go bishop g5 and black's d6 pawn is in a
lot of trouble here queen c7 we double
i mean the pressure grows quite immense
here
and this is
very very annoying
this is very very annoying
so knight d7
knight d7
defending
the bishop on
e5 essentially and asking us
whether we should trade the bishop and
and this leads us to another important
dilemma should we take on e5 or not now
we should understand about these types
of dilemmas
when you have these types of situations
it's usually not the case that there's a
very clear correct answer it might be
the case that taking on e5 is decent and
not taking any five is also decent
so we played rookie d1
because i was not worried about black
moving the bishop back we've already
established that bishop g5 here is
really really annoying and it's actually
even this is just bad flat out bad for
black because the queen cannot move we
win the pawn on d6
a lot of you at this point were
clamoring for for queen c4
which
at this point is a little bit more
appealing to me than on the previous
move
rook b6
and night g5 was suggested yeah very
interesting idea but what if black
defends the pawn like what's your
follow-up going to be are you going to
play f4
but if you play f4 then you give me this
check and you open up your king a little
bit
so i prefer to take a slightly more
positional approach
it just seems like you're making one
move threats but black has the bandwidth
to defend against them and your fingers
are going to stop slipping start
slipping from the ledge at some point
so notice how patiently we're
accumulating the pressure here rookie d1
rook v6 and now we decided to grab the
bishop on e5
because
here i really liked the way the rooks
were cooperating amongst each other one
of the rooks is pressuring d6 the other
rook is setting up the idea of bishop g5
and perhaps setting up the idea of a
kingside attack also it was pretty
important for me to establish
that knight c6 here
which would otherwise be a very annoying
move could be met with bishop b2 and we
control the d4 square in time we have
this diagonal black's king is in
quite a bit of trouble here in the long
run
so queen f6 was was played now we go
bishop h6 developing with tempo
rook fb8 and now queen d2 to hit the
pawn on a5 hit the pawn on d6 just
trying to continually optimize the
placement of our pieces here if rotates
b3 would have happened this is just
suicidal because we take on d6 and now
there's all sorts of threats black's
position falls apart here
so i think our opponent's move c4 was
actually pretty good
trade queen e2 and white is better here
of course
the the the like end of the game was
very disappointing
black should have dropped the knight
back to e5 and here the game continues i
mean white is better but my guess would
be something like plus one maybe we go
back to e3 with the bishop trying to
weaken the d6 pawn even further
not totally sure what
what white should undertake here
but our opponent panic dirk b2
queen takes c4 resigns because queen
takes f2 check king h2 and the pawn on
g2 is defended there is uh yeah there
there's a lot of positional richness to
this game even though it was only 29
moves thank you for the bits
unfortunately i do have to take off so
i'm going to have to pause here all
right later
[Music]